we're not big believers in legacy i  don't think that inherited wealth does  anyone any good i think it ruins people  money is a tool  and my favorite magic card which there's  a game called matching the gathering i  played was a kid but it was um she  wished for a weapon but not the skill to  wield it and so i think that people get  this very powerful tool and they don't  have the skill to wield it i think the  only way to not have money own you  is to know how to generate it and then  you can respect it for what it is know  what its limitations are and know what  you can use it for but if i did have  kids i still wouldn't give them the  money  because they have to they have to do it  on their own i think it'll ruin them